israel en la mira de la onu según un
informe de la comisión encargada por el
consejo de derechos humanos de la onu la
ocupación de territorios palestinos y la
discriminación de la población palestina
son las causas principales de la
inestabilidad y de las tensiones
habituales en la región las conclusiones
sobre las causas de este conflicto
apuntan en su mayoría israel lo que
indica la naturaleza asimétrica del
conflicto y la realidad de un estado que
ocupa a otro la comisión se estableció
luego en la guerra de los 11 días que se
libró entre israel y hamas en mayo del
2021 causando la muerte de 260
palestinos y 13 israelíes pero
rápidamente esta comisión fue criticada
estados unidos país que regresó al
consejo de derechos humanos bajo la
voluntad de joe biden reafirmó su fuerte
oposición a una comisión a la que acusa
de ser parcial y sesgada el ministro de
asuntos exteriores israelí acusó a los
investigadores de tomar partido en
ginebra frente a la sede de naciones
unidas manifestantes israelíes se
reunieron para denunciar lo que ellos
describen como uno donde la onu contra
su país
el consejo considera que israel es un
estado que practica el apartheid que
comete crímenes de guerra es una
verdadera cacería de brujas
de human rigth el consejo de derechos
humanos es el órgano más antisemita del
mundo están obsesionados por el estado
de israel y la emprenden constantemente
contra el game israel asimismo la
comisión de investigación estima que las
múltiples recomendaciones hechas a
israel sobre las violaciones de derechos
humanos han sido ignoradas en un
silencio cómplice del estado de hebreo
según la onu